Ukrainian officials are warning
Russia is gearing up to what
they're describing as maximum
escalation just ahead of a
possible spring military
offensive against Ukraine.
CNN's correspondent Fred
pleitgen has our report from the
frontlines.
[ Gunfire ]
>> Reporter: All-out warfare on
the eastern front.
We're in a trench with Ukrainian
paratroopers.
As they fire on Russian
positions using aks and a U.S.
Supplied browning heavy machine
gun.
They're searching for weak spots
in our position, says the
commander, call sign ghost.
They want to see if we fight
back.
If we show strong resistance,
they don't advance.
And this is what strong
resistance looks like.
The Lu Russians are only about 400
yards away, hidden in the snow
and fog, but constantly firing
at the entrinched Ukrainian.
The enemy uses small arms, heavy
machine guns, artillery,
mortars, rocket launchers and
aviation, as well.
But so far, the Ukrainians say
they haven't lost an inch of
territory here.
The Ukrainians say the situation
here is reminiscent of some of
the worst times in World War II
where they are not only fighting
a strong adversary but the
elements, as well.
The snow, the mud, and the cold
make fighting here even tougher.
And Ukraine's leadership
believes the Russians will soon
escalate even more after
mobilizing hundreds of thousands
of men for a likely spring
offensive.
But this gunner, who goes by the
name deputy, says the
paratroopers are ready.
"It will be hard, it will be
tough, but we will hold because
we stand here for our land.
If we don't do it, nobody will."
There's a visceral hatred
towards Moscow's leaders among
these men.
"In Russia, they have a
terrorist regime, so now the
civilized world is fighting
against this evil dictatorship."
As we prepare to leave, incoming
grenades explode.
They expect much worse in the
months to come, but their Moto
is, if not us, who else?
Wolf, when the Ukrainians talk
about that, they also say they
believe especially the moblmonths of
February and March are going to
be tough for them.
Some of the things we are
seeing, there are several places
that we have been to where the
Ukrainians are saying they are
already seeing the Russians beef
up forces, especially with those
people that they mobilized
towards the end of last year.
So they do expect that there is
going to be a large-scale
offensive coming from the
Russians.
As you heard there from the
paratroopers, they believe they
can stand their ground.
However, they say they are going
to need western weapons, weapons
from the U.S. And allies to make
that happen.
Wolf?
>> Fred, thank you very much.
Fred pleitgen in the war zone
for us.
Stay safe over there, Fred.
Appreciate it very much.
I want to dig deeper.
Joining us retired colonel
Cedric Layton, a CNN military
analyst.
And the former defense
secretary.
Russia is gearing up for what
they're calling maximum
escalation.
What are you watching for as
Russia clearly ramps up its
military offensive?
>> Wolf, the main things that
I'm watching for are how the
Russians are disposing of their
forces, where they're putting
them, how they're moving them,
are there new troop
concentrations in specific
areas?
So for the most part what we are
seeing and what the Ukrainians
are seeing is that moving into
the eastern areas, the areas
where Fred was just at, these
are really indications that the
Russians are moving their forces
forward.
Mainly the conscripts.
But they're moving some of their
more experienced units, like the
airborne units into bakhmut.
That indicates that they really
believe that particular city,
that particular town is one that
they need to capture at this
point.
>> Evalyn, what more does
Ukraine need right now to
prepare for this major Russian
escalation that's coming, as it
is clearly waiting for these
western battle tanks to be
deployed?
>> Well, wolf, you heard Fred
talk about the fact that the
Russians have air power or they
have air, you know, essentially
power that they can employ
through the air.
And I think this is what is
missing for the Ukrainians.
You know going back several
months, the Ukrainians were
trying to get the soviet era
fighter aircraft from the poles
and other nato allies.
And that didn't work.
I am hopeful that now, given
this new offensive, that we will
turn around and, you know, the
U.S. Can say we'll provide F-16s
if that's the green light
required, the cover required.
But we need to provide the
Ukrainians aircraft so they can
provide cover for troops on the
ground.
>> Let me follow up with colonel
Layton.
You served in the air force.
Why is Ukraine pleading for
these fighter jets from the U.S.
And allies, despite U.S.
Opposition that the jets -- the
U.S. Arguing the jets would be
"Impractical."
>> Yeah, so the Ukrainians
believe that they can use these
jets with a minimum amount of
training, wolf.
I think the fact of the matter,
is when you look at how pilots
are trained, it can take up to a
year to train pilots in certain
airplanes.
In the case of the Ukrainians, I
think we're looking at somewhere
between 3 to 8 months of
training, so that requires
something.
There is also the logistical
tail to be considered, and the
right tactics have to be
developed and used by the newly
minted f-16 pilots.
So the U.S. Is reluctant to do
this because of a lot of these
considerations.
But if the Ukrainians can prove
to the U.S. That they can use
these aircraft and use them
effectively, then perhaps the
green light will happen in spite
of objections we hear right now.
>> Evalyn, the Israeli prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu told
CNN exclusively last night in an
interview with Jake tapper that
he would be willing to mediate
between Russia and Ukraine.
Listen to this, listen to this
exchange.
>> If I'm asked by both sides,
and frankly, if I'm asked by the
United States.
You can't have too many cooks in
the kitchen.
If asked by all relevant
parties, I would certainly
consider it.
But I'm not pushing myself in.
I think this is of monumental
peace, because I think the peace
of the world is at stake.
>> What is your reaction,
Evalyn?
>> Everyone wants to be a
mediator, but the situation
isn't right for mediation.
Vladamir Putin is hardly ready
to back down, as you hear the
Ukrainians saying.
In fact, the Russians
themselves.
They're ready to launch another
assault.
They are not giving up.
And obviously, same thing for
the Ukrainians.
They're not giving up any square
footage of their land.
So that's not a situation that's
ripe for negotiation.
One side needs to be winning or
both sides need to feel like
they're losing.
So what prime minister Netanyahu
is offering is fine, but
frankly, what Israel needs to
offer is weaponry to the
Ukrainians so they can defeat
the Russians and defeat this vie
relate, aggressive international